o pão especial visa mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer o tradicional
barquinho de papel com mastro
mas este é um jogo diferente uma vez que
olhei de sinai uma dobra faz com que a
água não entra dentro do barquinho e
assim possa navegar por mais tempo então
bora lá e é para fazer isso daqui vão
precisar de uma folha a4 impressora ou
então do sul feito em primeiro lugar à
folha a mãe
o brasil outra vez
não vou abrir e fazer dois treinos de
tangos nesta linha do centro
vai fazer o outro aqui
é um lugar na primeira água e dobrar
aqui nesta parte
a contrário encara os dois triângulos
pra dentro
um que outro
agora vamos dobrar isso aqui estava com
a outra
cuidado pra ficar tudo com o mesmo nível
era o contrário do brasil os treinos
para dentro também
foi do chapéu na cabeça assim
agora é só o vincar que esta parte do
trauma ou imaginar uma linha imaginária
vai desde pequim até extra e do brasil
vem com um vinco que este lado
embora seja mesmo presta para nada
encontraram
vamos fazer isto mais uma vez bridge
alencar vai imaginar a linha
agora vamos abrir
o marquinhos está acabado mas se vocês
fizerem assim na água vai acontecer é
que vai entrar água por esta parte aqui
então para que isso não aconteça para
fazer uma pequena obra para levantar
esta parte aqui eu vou fazer assim e
fazer um pequeno triângulo nesta para
aproximar pra vocês verem melhor
descobri o triângulo está por um lado
afastar para o outro e agora foi para o
triângulo para dentro e fora do brasil
está assim
vejam fica uma barreira e água não vai
entrar dentro do banco e só despertam
estado é só uma coisa se vocês forem
usar isto branco um parque no lar
qualquer
não esqueça de nos mover os barquinhos
aqui para não incluir uma ambiente em
salto obrigado ter sido até à próxima
etapa